Frank Grillo is one of those guys that
people know either the Marvel movies and
all that how many Marvel movies have you
done three
Winter Soldier now I'm doing DC now
you're doing the crossover yeah that's
right with gun wait what did you do with
gun no I'm about to oh you can't say it
no I just got hired so you can't say
what you're doing no you can't say the
project no because I get in trouble
because there's a million projects who
knows what it is right right it's their
first yeah
yeah well as long as you're not playing
[__] Lex Luthor I'm not playing like
sloth only one person could play no
that's true he's doing a completely
different version because he's like are
you gonna play you're good friends with
James you know James is a very close
friend of mine I'm like dude he's got a
whole new thing figured out there's like
a whole no I'm not like if he wants to
give me your wall let me give me a ride
[__] you you're one of my best friends
if you you know what I could do right if
you want to hire me hire me I'm not
going to sit here I don't do that [__]
I'm not begging for fun I don't know I
have oh grudges but no no no I don't I
mean I mean the Marvel movies I mean do
you find look I obviously probably can't
say but do you think like you know back
in our time where it was like where does
the loss came right there's the Lost Ark
came out yeah you know and then you had
to wait two years for Temple of Doom or
Star Wars came out and then three years
for I love that I loved the waiting and
the anticipation and then but now it's
like almost every weekend there's a
million kill listen I first of all I
don't know I don't know what covet has
done to the movie business but you know
when I did Captain America Winter
Soldier Marvel was not they had done and
by the way people love that that's a
great movie that's right as a movie
itself not as a Marvel yeah it's a great
movie also Logan yes yeah I didn't see
it but the people told me Logan it's
fantastic yeah it's very dark it's
really cool yeah
um and so it was Winter Soldier but you
waited for the next like and then all of
a sudden Marvel blew up and you know now
so many different directions now it's
all over the place now almost seems like
it's all the same so who cares you got
to make it special yeah you know what I
mean so I think they need to kind of and
I think they are I think that now
they're gonna put out less how about
three movies a year yeah you know three
great movies a year thank you thank you
and by the way they got to be careful
with the Star Wars it's everywhere too
there it's like yeah and what happens
they get backlash they mandalorian's
brilliant right but then you got the
other series that are just like oh this
and this and I'm not saying I hate them
but like solo and all these other to me
I'm a giant Star Wars fan I'm like don't
care I don't care don't care man Lauren
I finally care right right just make let
John Favreau be in charge of everything
there you go John Favreau by the way
brilliant he's brilliant yeah I love
John Favre yeah he's he's he directed my
favorite movie ever let me guess elf
yeah I love it Jimmy Khan Jimmy Khan
see that movie made me cry when I had
the slay when it comes at the end I cry
I [__] cried it out I know